Доброго дня Сьогодні я на Зінкевич
ветеранка бойових дій
хочу поговорити з вами про важливий
закон закон про канабіс
зараз він не надзвичайно актуальним я
переступаю перед вами як людина з
інвалідністю як людина яка отримала
чотири контузії як людина яка на війні
отримала 10 черепно-мозкових травм при
зіткненні з іншим транспортом бойовим як
людина яка зараз поламала навіть на
візку дві ноги
Кожного дня я страждаю від болю від болю
страшного від болю нетерпимого від болю
якого хочеться плакати
кожен день в нашій країні таких людей
страждає десятків і сотні тисяч кожного
дня вони отримали бтср вони отримали
якісь бойові травми вони отримали
цивільні травми це не є якоюсь різницею
нам потрібно розуміти і кожному з нас що
зараз і в нас
вирішується від нашого рішення
вирішується доля цих людей доля людей
які вже готові нелегально десь Купляти
щось робити
переходити на наркотичні засоби Чого вам
не хотілося і робити все для того щоб
отримати єдине знеболення тому що коли
ти живеш З таким
кожну секунду ти думаєш тільки про це
я переборюю себе
працюючи в наших лавах працюючи за
Україну роблять Чи свій батальйон
госпітальєри і працюючи кожного дня над
ним але кожну секунду дається мені
великою тягнутою тому я від себе від
наших пацієнтів від наших друзів якої
велика кількість в нас на жаль Уже понад
півтора мільйона ветеранів
Я прошу вас проголосувати за цей закон
так він зараз трошки не ідеальний але
дуже багатьом фракціям і знаючи сказали
що врахують їхні поправки і я як член
комітету охорони здоров'я обов'язково
також допомогу щоб їх
врахували тому моє прохання і прохання
пацієнтів сьогодні підтримати цей закон
і обов'язково не обійти його увагу
навіть якщо зараз він не ідеальний дякую
[оплески]